[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsables inició
esta semana la evacuación de civiles de
la planta siderúrgica de las hospital el
último foco de la resistencia ucraniana
en la asediada mariupol sin embargo
cientos de personas se mantienen
atrapadas en esta ciudad portuaria del
mar de azov con su nueva estrategia
militar en esta segunda fase de la
guerra rusia ha intensificado sus
embestidas en el sur del país contra
ciudades como do deza por ejemplo la
destrucción de la infraestructura en la
ciudad de mykolaiv ha dejado a los
residentes con serias dificultades para
acceder al servicio de agua potable el
siguiente es un informe de nuestra
unidad especial catalina gómez anal
lina empieza el día recolectando agua
desde hace tres semanas las tuberías que
abastecía mykolaiv quedaron destruidas
la ciudad ha quedado sin abastecimiento
un tropiezo más en una larga lista de
dificultades que trae la guerra
y el problema más grande que tenemos es
nuestra seguridad porque tenemos
explosiones ataques con misiles y es muy
peligroso
fue la noche cerca de las nueve o diez
de la noche
más de 100 civiles han muerto en ataques
en el área urbana de mykolaiv
esta bomba cayó a pocos metros de su
casa y
fue en la noche cerca de las nueve o
diez de la noche
veamos
aún bajo las amenazas de los bombardeos
y los problemas que trae la guerra y lin
ha preferido quedarse en la ciudad
tiene 67 años y vivió la primera mitad
de su vida en la unión soviética
y si me dicen hace un año y medio que
esta situación se daría en mi país me lo
hubiera creído
eso fue tan inesperado tan horrible
tener una guerra en medio de europa
elena y su hija también repiten el
ritual de recolectar agua lo hacen
cuando las condiciones de seguridad se
los permiten después de trabajar
duramente por años ahora les preocupa su
supervivencia
no trabajo ahora la seguridad no lo
permite pero recibo salario pero es
mucho menor de lo que era y no es
suficiente para vivir
este café ha decido reabrir sus puertas
los empleados dicen que se las arreglan
para lidiar con problemas como la
escasez de agua
obviamente el salario es menor pero
vamos bien sin embargo muchos de mis
amigos perdieron el trabajo jóvenes como
lisa esperan que la línea de defensa
resistan mientras tanto ella pelea por
no dejar que la esperanza que destruida
por la guerra
mientras se recrudecen los combates en
la región del tumbas las tropas rusas se
han retirado de la gran mayoría de las
ciudades del norte de ucrania para los
residentes de estas zonas llegó el
momento de la reconstrucción es el
ejemplo de boro dianca una de las
ciudades más destruidas por el conflicto
vamos al siguiente informe una
colaboración de nuestros colegas de
fondo y france24
un ejemplo entre muchos otros de la
magnitud de la destrucción en boro janka
y de la enorme tarea de reconstrucción
que se avecina antes de la guerra estos
dos edificios eran uno solo pero un
bombardeo ruso a principios de marzo
destruyó la parte central ya no queda
nada 40 por ciento de las estructuras
están afectadas la reconstrucción parece
imposible pero los habitantes están
convencidos de que si es posible en este
barrio estos trabajadores se encargan
del primer paso la demolición de las
casas que están demasiado dañadas como
aquí estamos quitando las tuberías de
gas para que los demás servicios puedan
intervenir arrasar los edificios y
reconstruir otros nuevos una vez
terminada la búsqueda de las víctimas la
vida como era antes tardará meses
probablemente años en volver pero este
residente está dispuesto a esperar
volver un día no rendirse al enemigo a
pesar del trauma aunque nueve de sus
vecinos han desaparecido
vamos a quedarnos aquí hay que
reconstruir por odian acá tenemos que
ponernos a trabajar soy un antiguo
soldado no quiero irme
cuando todavía es posible como en estas
viviendas sociales los habitantes se
apresuran a reparar
será posible volver aquí tan pronto como
se restablezca el gas y la electricidad
tras la limpieza esta mujer procede al
inventario de lo que los ocupantes le
han robado
reconstruir es también volver a comprar
las ventanas se habían caído y las
reparamos pero nos robaron las joyas la
ropa la comida también creo que tenían
hambre incluso nos robaron la basura el
futuro devoró dianca dependerá de los
medios financieros que se le concedan
quién pagará por ejemplo las obras de
las numerosas casas destruidas los
habitantes a menudo no tienen el dinero
necesario y el estado ve como su
economía se hunde por la guerra por el
momento el 90 por ciento del flujo de
efectivo de la ciudad proviene de la
ayuda humanitaria los hospitales de
ucrania se han convertido en uno de los
principales objetivos de esta guerra son
al menos 180 los centros hospitalarios
que han sido atacados en todo el país
los más de 65 días que ha durado este
conflicto
nuestras enviadas especiales irene sabio
y leticia álvarez viajaron al frente en
un convoy humanitario para trasladar dos
ambulancias tres hospitales de jarque
o lo que significa el convoy humanitario
hacia jarquín la segunda ciudad más
importante del país y donde la
artillería rusa dispara a diario
este voluntario ucraniano sabe qué
significa trabajar bajo el sonido de los
proyectiles fue uno de los primeros en
evacuar a civiles de la ciudad asediada
de espn cerca de kiev
muchos eran mujeres con niños se llaman
los lleve cerca del puente cerca de
irving
son dos horas de viaje en las que hay
que pasar por varios check points donde
la ayuda humanitaria se mezcla con
vehículos militares en jarquín nos
espera se reactive el oncólogo de
radiología jefe de servicio del hospital
este centro es el único que hay para
tratar a todos los enfermos de cáncer de
la región
por desgracia el único dispensario
regional para oncología está dañado y
todos los médicos que trabajan allí lo
dejaron incluso ahora en ese centro hay
combates activos y los proyectiles
llegan a esa zona
son sólo cinco doctores y cuatro
enfermeras para tratar a los pacientes
porque el resto de profesionales o bien
se fueron a otros países o simplemente
se quedaron atrapados en zonas
controladas por los rusos de un modo
lento y es por encima de un acceso que
el co2 en mi casa está en zona de
combate por eso desde el primer día vivo
y trabajo aquí
según estos sueños
muchas personas viven aquí y sus
familias porque no pueden volver a sus
casas por la guerra o porque sus casas
están destruidas
las consecuencias de la invasión rusa en
ucrania se reflejan en los hospitales
víctor estaréis que es el director del
centro de salud tienen 100 pacientes de
los cuales sólo 50 pueden recibir
radioterapia al día porque es el máximo
que puede trabajar el aparato necesitan
equipos de tratamiento para taparle
primo esfuerzo y de listo esta máquina
puede ayudar a muchas personas ahora es
la única de este tipo que hay en el
sureste de ucrania necesitamos muchísimo
un acelerador lineal tenemos equipo de
médicos muy bueno para el seguimiento un
oscar lusich phillips eve y alexei tiene
72 años empezó su tratamiento en plena
guerra es difícil estar enfermo con la
guerra es muy difícil con los
medicamentos nos ayudan desde el oeste
de ucrania he pasado por la
quimioterapia y ahora tengo que
someterme a radioterapia buscamos en
kharkiv una farmacia que tenemos cerca
es muy difícil harkov es una de las
ciudades más atacadas y bombardeadas
desde el inicio de la invasión rusa como
este edificio de la universidad de la
administración regional todos los días
calla artillería aquí casi todos los
días hay heridos y fallecidos pero los
recursos son limitados los trabajadores
de la salud que quedan en esta ciudad
resisten y se resguardan durante los
ataques en los sótanos habilitados como
refugios antiaéreos 24 horas después de
grabar este reportaje un hospital muy
cercano fue bombardeado en kharkiv otro
más en esta guerra donde los sanitarios
luchan por tratar a sus pacientes
de rusia a silvia el grupo mercenario
ruso wagner está reclutando activamente
combatientes en los países donde opera
para apuntalar las fuerzas de moscú en
ucrania el kremlin ha negado
sistemáticamente cualquier conexión con
esta organización paramilitar privada
pero el compromiso de wagner con los
intereses rusos es evidente las ofertas
de trabajo que se han encontrado en
línea sugieren que el grupo está
ampliando su área de reclutamiento
veamos el siguiente informe de dalián
slinger martín la vio en round máximo
algunos clics es todo lo que se necesita
para encontrar los anuncios el grupo
mercenario ruso wagner está reclutando y
lo está dando a conocer ha publicado
decenas de ofertas de trabajo durante
los dos últimos meses el grupo que una
vez estuvo oculto ya no se molesta en
esconderse quieres vivir tu sueño de
unirte al ejército pero no has tenido la
oportunidad de hacerlo con el grupo
wagner usted podría unirse a una campaña
en un país extranjero cercano solo unas
fotos a testigos a la presencia de
wagner en ucrania según los servicios de
inteligencia británicos hay más de 1000
de sus combatientes en primera línea y
necesitan más
sitio que se utilizan como carne de
cañón porque son los primeros en ser
enviados a la primera línea a los campos
de batalla y por eso están sufriendo
grandes pérdidas están buscando
socorristas expertos en anti minado
operadores de lanzacohetes pero que así
cualquier hombre entre 24 y 50 años
sirve los requisitos son muchos menos
estrictos que para los cargos que
ofrecen en áfrica servicio militar
previo no esencial no importa si tiene
deudas o problema tales se toleran
antecedentes penales aunque hay algunas
líneas rojas no solicitantes con
sentencias aún no cumplidas sin familia
en países de la otan el salario es
también 50 por ciento más alto que en
áfrica
240 mil rublos o alrededor de tres mil
euros al mes enviamos un mensaje a uno
de los números de contacto publicados
haciéndonos pasar por un hombre de 35
años sin experiencia militar la
respuesta llegó 15 minutos después
invitándonos al centro de reclutamiento
y prometiéndonos un 95 por ciento de
posibilidades de ser aceptados la
reunión tiene lugar en lo que llaman el
campamento de vacaciones en el suroeste
de rusia muy cerca de un punto de
concentración del ejército ruso se hacen
pasar por una prueba de detección de
mentiras para asegurarse de que no eres
un periodista o un espía por ejemplo
pero no hacen ninguna prueba psicológica
lo cual es un problema porque terminan
reclutando locos de librar pues los
nuevos reclutas pasan algunas semanas en
estos barracones
de trasladarse a campos de entrenamiento
o incluso directamente al frente
queremos agradecer a casa galería café
por prestarnos sus instalaciones para
grabar nuestro programa ustedes también
muchas gracias por seguir un nuevo
episodio de corresponsales nos damos
cita la próxima semana siga con más
información en trans 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]